once again welcome to my talk and it's
my pleasure today to introduce all those
image processing features that we have
that are applicable to microscopy well
maybe I should say upfront microscopy is
a vast area and we're just covering very
tiny bit currently mostly what is
concerned with light microscopy and I'm
not talking about all the other ways you
can obtain images from micro or nano
scale so well the abstract you should
have read I guess but here's the outline
of today's talk I've tried to bring it
up in to two parts part number one for
those who are not into microscopy I'll
explain a little bit what the typical
workflow would be if you do obtain
microscopic images and I'd like to
process them in Mathematica and then in
the second part of today's talk I'll
talk about some applications
well most applications are that you
measure features and image and
microscopy oh that you do counting cell
accounting stuff like that but I also
will do some things that you probably
can't do in any other software than
Mathematica so the first part is like
catching up with others already have and
the second part is to show that you can
do things that others can't do in
Mathematica
all right so typical microscopy
workplace nowadays looks somewhat like
this you don't sit over your microscope
and look through an ocular anymore you
have on a CCD camera or at the CCD
sensor mounted on the ocular and all the
images that are obtained in the
microscope are directly fed into a
computer system in form of all kinds of
file formats up there then I'd like to
point out that usually a microscope
nowadays comes with a moveable a stage
so the stage where the specimen is
mounted on because the problem
microscopy is that you feel the vision
is rather small because you enlarge so
much to just see a very tiny portion of
your specimen and in order to get a
bigger picture you just have to move
that specimen around so you don't take
just one picture usually but you take a
whole entire array of pictures then
we'll talk a little bit about how to
obtain images in mathema
how to import them and more importantly
how to get the meta information and then
I'll talk about what you usually do when
you obtain images so you have to do some
pre-processing step you have to correct
for all the shortcomings of the
microscope like CCD misalignment correct
faulty pixels in the CCD or correct for
uneven illumination I do two time
reasons I just focus on the letter one
the other ones I think straight straight
forward somewhat and then as I mentioned
you have to assemble images because you
don't just take one image but a whole
array of images then I have a one point
here which I probably can skip because
Giulio wasn't my kind that already
talked took all my slides even and
talked about it and then I just talked
about here quickly how to combine two
the images in 3d volumes and then comes
the interesting part for those who do
know Mathematica and want to go beyond
what can be done so far I will show how
to present large images in Mathematica
with dynamic image which is a new object
I will show how you can write with
dynamic interested I make interface
dynamic measurement front ends in
Mathematica show you how do you do
object object segmentation and then some
automatic measurements and
quantification programs all right first
up there's a huge or vast array of file
formats just for microscopy and we
haven't come around to implement all
those yet and the best way to cope with
this shortcoming in Mathematica is to
utilize what's called bio formats sorry
that should be yes there it's a software
project that is out there that you can
download it's for free it's just that if
you want to use it commercially it's not
for free so we can't just incorporate
that in Mathematica but you can easily
attach it to Mathematica and basically
once you download my talk you have
already everything installed you can
just run the following step using a Java
link sorry J link and that will help you
to hook up to that particular
package so first what you would have to
do is you would have to load j-link then
reinstall your java implementation and
assign more memory to it then establish
a place where you want to put the whole
package and then unless you already have
the package or have that folder that you
just established you have to create it
and then well I won't do that because it
would cost time and I already did that
before you just have to execute this
command and this will automatically load
the jar the Java jar from the internet
into your system at the right location
and then all that needs to be done is to
hook up to it
and some utility classes and that's it
that's the whole installation of this
bio format object so it can easily be
done in Mathematica and then you can
build with Java link or j-link sorry
some functions on it like import of bio
format or an import of bio format
metadata and then we can see if this
works so let me try define here in
relation to my notebook
the path to a5 a file called embryo this
particular file is in Britain an open
lab lef F so somewhat similar stiff and
then I just call up here at the command
import bio format image and this will
load the image this image format into
Mathematica and just to prove that I
actually did obtain something I'll just
manipulate this here and it's not just a
single image but it's a whole stack of
images and you can just zoom through it
and visualize what you see in this
particular image and then on top of it
it's quite helpful to load the metadata
as well but unfortunately in this
particular case the pixel size is not in
the metadata I think and that's still
something we try to work on to
automatically deduce typical pixel size
that are in these images so that it can
do measurements more naturally okay
so once we have the images we can start
to
try to put things together and what I
have here is so it just works a little
faster a whole list of images of a DNA
actually it's an array of four times
four images each image just one
megapixel large and those are try to
combine now well we do have image line
and so you can could do that principle
yourself but it's a lot of wiggling and
trying to get things straight so with
this torque comes the command that's
called stitch image array so it's a kind
of a preliminary stitching command that
you welcome to use and that will allow
me to automatically align these this
array in a very robust manner I just
have to provide two variables one is the
amount of overlap that I have between
every image so in this case it's 128
pixels and then also the variants
because the stage will never be
completely exact but you can at least
get these from the microscope these
variables these parameters and then
you're automatically and I just have pre
calculated that because it takes a
roughly 30 seconds you can obtain an
image like this now if you look closely
you will see that you see a grid in this
image and that's typically what happens
because the illumination of the specimen
under microscope is usually not even so
we have to actually go back now one step
and correct for illumination
deficiencies of the microscope and what
you can do is take a blank image so that
you get an idea or get the whole
sequences of blank images so you get an
idea what the illumination of this
particular microscope looks like and so
if I have this one here variable the
elimination has this unevenness so it's
really not that eveness as one would
assume would like to have it to be so
all I have to do then is just generate a
kind of a correction mass by taking the
rest of procorp that particular case and
they're just at Machine epsilon to avoid
division by zero and then I can multiply
this correction term onto all these
stars that I had before and then if I
repeat the stitching I get
whoops here we go a perfect resulting
image well the image is actually much
bigger I just downscaled it so we have
it here faster okay as I said the any
bigger sorry no I'll get there in a
second this a wall skip you saw that
particular slide already before it's
about image stacking because you not
just take several images that are
spatially separated but you also take
images that are separated by the focal
depth and in order to combine them
images as well I repeated anyway as
julia has shown you have one focal depth
another one another one and then you can
combine with image focus combine all
these to an entire image with a deeper
focal length alright so once you have
that you end up usually with fairly big
images and unfortunately so far when you
have an image object in mathematica
either you make it automatically smaller
so it fits into your notebook or well it
just doesn't fit and you have a hard
time viewing it and because of that we
now have come up with a command that's
called image a dynamic image and that
allows you to do two things first of all
it allows you to look at very large
images without getting the entire image
into memory because there are images out
there that are gigabytes big and then
you won't have the capability of
actually having everything in your RAM
so this is an out of course setup it's
again the rDNA image the stitched one
that I have done before so it's not
really that big and this dynamic image
basically comes up with a viewing window
just like on a Google Earth for example
that you just see a poor part of the
image and you have different ways now to
zoom pan scroll in this viewing pan
first of all you have these scroll bars
but they are not ordinary scroll bars
they have these handles on the side
which allow you to stretch them or make
them shorter and doing so you loop in
and out accordingly so basically then
the zoom bar down here gives you an
indication how large of a portion of the
original image you're viewing current
you can just put your mouse on it move
around Russians you can use these
buttons to zoom in and out you can have
a bigger viewing area and so forth and
all of this is fairly still fairly
responsive even though all the data
needs to be loaded into Mathematica as I
go and then of course I can do the same
here with images in memory and so it
looks just look and feel is very much
alike it can move it around like this
and furthermore you can with these
options have access to these dynamic
features of that image for example you
can control not just in this image
itself the scale or the position you can
also have here these controls outside
and build your own interface with all
these gimmicks that you can think of so
you can also unfortunate I don't have
that prepared to have two images side by
side and just synchronously zoom in zoom
out pan around and compare alright
and then at the end of the day the big
objective in microscopy is to actually
measure things and here Mathematica
gives you the total freedom to construct
any kind of measuring device on your
image as you like because you can just
with epilogue basically construct any
kind of graphics object on that image in
an image coordinate system and you can
still zoom in and out pan around so this
is again an image of the embryo just one
slice I can zoom in I can zoom out I can
move around here the position of the
circle and I can change the radius of
the circle and thereby in a way
measuring for example here there the
size of the cell down here and just by
looking now at the size I can read off
the radius and do similar measurements
like distance measurements contour
length and so forth okay so all these
necessities and microscopy are built in
and the last one because it gets much
more popular nowadays you can take we
can basically generate volume
with microscopic data whether you just
constantly slice off a specimen and just
take one image at a time so you get a
whole stack or you have other means to
obtain different layers of information
and in Mathematica all you have to do is
take the stack of images place it in an
image at 3d in this case I resize it
because the y-direction was a little bit
at a different resampling than the x and
y direction and then by just threshold
engrailed values around it I can have a
fairly good impression what the 3d
distribution of that particular cell
looks like I can turn it I can do
measurements in it whatever I can do in
on volumes I can now also do on these
volumes from microscopy all right so
this is a little bit like the typical
workflow you would have in the software
that most cases nowadays comes with a
microscope except that you now can also
do that in Mathematica and now I will
show you a few steps of what you can do
of what's possible in Mathematica to
construct your own programs to work on
microscopic data so typical scenario you
have a pathology an image of a set of
samples or cells and you have to count
the cells and you possibly also have to
classify the cells so the first task at
hand here is to actually segment the
cells to see where's the cell with
background background and for that
purpose I do a trick in image processing
I first look at that image at this
typical scale of a cell so it's just
like squinting a little bit with your
eyes and just seeing a bit more diffused
and you just don't see the details of
the cell but you see where cells are and
this is what I basically have obtained
here with a laplacian caution filter it
gives me a certain scale the typical
scale of a cell and then I can just
count or see where they are Maxima and
these Maxima typically now the positions
of each cell so I just already got very
quickly and very easily
the these cell seeds and these centers
points of these cells are now used as
seeds in a region growing
algorithm he and region binarize it
basically grows from that seed and tries
to fill the entire cell and that's what
I get unfortunately I do have here a few
holes in the cell so I use a filling
transform which basically now gives me a
fairly robust segmentation of all these
cells and just by doing a little bit of
post-processing taking away a pixel on
the boundary so I don't have too many
sit on extent into the background which
can happen with reaching binarize and
I'll have a segmentation and I can see
if that segmentation makes sense and as
you can see all the orange parts are the
cells that have been recognized and
except for those well not clearly
defined cells down here it has done a
fairly good job and then the second step
usually is to really do routinized
scrutinized and to select certain cell
types and for that purpose in
Mathematica we have select components so
you have here components due to the
segmentation and then every component
can be selected with this command by
providing any kind of criteria for any
kind of property that we provide here
like area circularity elongation and so
forth and in this case I get away with
just measuring cells the cell area and
the circularity of a cell so the round
cells are typically more circular than
the star like cells so by just selecting
cells of a certain size and where the
circularity is not too high I get all
the sickle cells that are like sorry and
the starlike cells in this case and then
I can do a count and prove measurements
on data so this would be a very typical
application another typical application
is like in fluoroscopy in fluorescence
microscopy is to see how much
fluorescence is taken up by certain
types of cells to do these kind of
measurements and this is a data set we
obtained from Professor Roy yet a UIUC
next door and what this is it's
basically a set of cells brain cells I
think from a rat if I'm not mistaken and
the blue channel here just shows the
cells as they are and then an
different images has been registered and
put on top of this that shows the
fluorescent dye as it was taken up by
these cells and the question now is what
cells or how many cells actually did
take up the dye because those cells have
certain properties in contrast to others
and there's a bit misleading because if
you look at this here even if you have
certain areas a lot of fluorescence that
fluorescence doesn't have to be in a
cell and still I don't know how many
cells are taken and how many of the
cells actually are covered by
fluorescence and so forth so this is a
non-trivial task to do and the first
thing we have to do is basically again
do a segmentation of the the cells I do
now a different approach I first
basically take the background by
regularizing but somewhat smoothing the
whole thing with a diffusion filter
called Corona Malik that sustains the
the edges but otherwise blows away any
kind of morris art effects and then I
basically like to threshold now this
particular case but fresh holding is one
of the operations that are not too sexy
an image processing simply because you
have a parameter and if you fool around
with the parameter you things work or
they don't work and the question is what
is a good parameter setting so in order
to come up with a good algorithm you
have to have also good algorithm to
determine that threshold parameter in
this case I gave you give you here an
example on basically looking for the for
the boundaries of all these cells and I
find them by basically taking the second
derivative and then do a crossing detect
basically looking for the point where
the second derivative is zero and that's
the perfect boundary of a cell usually
under if you look at this as an edge
under well basically treating it like a
function in calculus and I try to find
these locations now with this procedure
here and find all the cells doing the
crossing detect on the laplacian filter
and then I multiply all these positions
with pixel values and then to do a
histogram so this basically gives me
then a histogram of what the grayscale
value is
the boundary of a cell and of course if
I basically positioned myself right and
the typical grayscale level of such a
boundary cell first by estimating here
this as a gamma distribution and then
finding the estimate like the median of
this distribution and take that as a
threshold I get a very robust threshold
to obtain these cells and now I can see
how well I'm doing here
first of all I have to identify the
brain cells now again do the same thing
as before I blur the whole thing I find
the Maxima and then I contract all the
cases where cells actually overlap well
is this going to be a bit fast I'm sorry
running out of time and so let me jump
ahead a little calculating now the cell
walls but take again the gradient filter
and then I obtained image like this here
basically a seed in every cell again and
kind of a wide wall around each cell due
to the gradient filter and now I apply a
different segmentation routine that is
called the watershed algorithm but that
basically looks for kind of water basins
in that kind of mountainscape landscape
that I have here just you imagine you
have rain falling down on this landscape
then the cells basically functioned like
water basins and that's exactly how I
determine here in this way the segments
of each cell and I create a mask out of
it and I can thereby see how well I'm
doing
segmenting this thing here I have no
lines everything in between everything
and then I basically extract these
segments and now I project the
fluoroscopy onto these segments and
basically see how large the overlap is
and each for each of that sack or for
each cell segment and that gives me then
a histogram of how much uptake each cell
has or how many cells have a certain
uptake and then I just extract here with
certain threshold all the cells that
have
at least 30% of the pixels being colored
by the fluorescent and then I can mask
that onto the create a mask and then use
that mask to highlight the area and this
is then the result all the pink cells
they are the ones that got actually
marked with the fluorescent or the other
ones shouldn't count okay one more
application this I gonna skip this is an
application or problem from material
science it's rather awkward it basically
gives you these kind of pictures of what
you see here is an alloy and the bubbles
they are tungsten bubbles and then lol I
forgot which it is exactly and to deduce
certain material properties you have to
find the angles between merging bubbles
so you have to measure the angle here
and here and so forth and this is a
rather tricky thing because depending on
what resolution you look at this the
angle does change so you have to specify
can only do this measurement properly by
defining a specific scale and then doing
that measurement at that scale and I do
this measurement well before I do the
measurement I just clean up the data a
little bit with the median filter
segmenting the thing deleting all the
tiny segments and then I basically now
have the bubbles defined and now I
basically don't go in here and measure
with some kind of wedge the angle but I
do is completely different you basically
can think of this as again mountainscape
and the ISO folds the lines of equal
brightness or fork between
foreground/background these lines
basically exhibit the curvature in these
angles yeah basically a contour goes
around and goes out again and I can
integrate the curvature of that contour
and then the integral of that curvature
will give you indication of what the
angle is is and then you can basically
read out the angle measurements just by
integrating over the curvature and I get
the curvature with different
well the mathematics explained it here
I'm a little bit short on time to go
into detail but the point is the
curvature of a photo of eiffel I'm sorry
I so fold or basically have a contour is
given by this expression so if you take
the luminosity or the brightness of the
image and take the second derivative and
xx and the square of the derivative of Y
and so forth
then we obtain copper which gives you
the curvature the curvature of the ISO
fold and this is done in this command
here in Mathematica and then I get this
kind of return this is basically now the
curvature strength and these these
wedges that I have in this particular
image and I just have to now basically
sum over all these values to obtain the
angle and I do this here first of all I
separate segments every angle
measurement because I don't want to sum
over two angles at the same time and
then I do my curvature measurements and
these are the curva measurements and
then I have to have some function that
translate the curvatures in two angles
and this I have done here but I won't go
into detail by it basically creating all
kinds of artificial examples with a
wedge and then just see what kind of
angle I get for certain curvature
readings at what scale I did this year
and at the end of the day I can
basically use tool tip to project onto
this image of my angle measurements and
just by going in there with a cursor I
can read out the angles like a hundred
and eight degrees this would be sixty
degrees because if you blur it it
actually would be combined this is 75
degrees and so forth so this is a
typical case scenario in Mathematica
that you have the freedom to program
anything you like and you can actually
do measurements that no other software
packages can do and this concludes my
little excursion into microscopy and
since I don't have outlook what's to
come so I bother suggest have a look
into the microscope and see what's
what's down there in the earth scale